[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour ça redémarre
j'avais prévu un programme pourtant et
je me retrouve à improviser
au début je me suis trompé l'adresse je
suis arrivé rue des marais m'ont dit
c'est pas ici qu'est je vais à côté d'un
magasin de musique je rentrerai cas j'y
suis je suis sûr d'avoir trouvé leur et
dollars et m'ont dit que non et mais à
côté il ya un bureau de change si jamais
là où le vrai dollars est alors j'ai
fait du changement j'ai changé mes
devises puis-je aller m'acheter des
chaussures cd reboot
c'est je crois que j'ai trouvé
j'arrive à la hache et une université
super je me sens pas à l'aise du tout
j'ai jamais fait d'études
comme d'habitude j'ai oublié mes
fournitures je n'ai rien à jeter
sauf un petit peu de thc bd j'ai dit
j'ai dit c'est mais drg dit cbd par
chance le thème aujourd'hui me plaît
beaucoup
moi même je suis chanteur de reggae on
en parle tout le temps
le changement je suis j'ai eu très bon
toc qui ont tous inspiré sur lesquels mr
très imagé j'ai trouvé des objets qui
vont permettre de m'aider à improviser
mais la croissance aujourd'hui atteint
des sommets en balance des sommes et des
sommes et des sommes même dans notre
sommeil ferait peut-être qu'on
redescende
en tout cas mieux consommer contraste on
sait jamais certains en ont très peu et
d'autres en font des tonnes
les contrastes aujourd'hui des tonnes et
m'étonne qu'on soit jeune qu'on soit
vieux l'idée du jeune pour partager
évidemment qu'elle est bonne donne nous
aujourd'hui notre pain de l'amour
j'espère que demain on pourra toujours
rallumer four hacking je me mets en mode
avion on sait jamais
chaque jeu chaque tu d'ailleurs aussi a
ses codes et sa version crackée tout le
monde ya des codes plus difficiles que
d'autres
faut-il hacker un système pour le
changer ou bien débrancher la tour de
contrôle carrément la saccager ou tout
simplement appuyer 10 secondes sur le
bouton la wii boot la relance et les
robots si le robot partagent nos vies
faudra-t-il se reprogrammer en tout cas
c'est le cas j'espère que dark verdure
et moi on partagera les mêmes idées je
vous laisse imaginer la médecine la
verte aulas jaune le choix est évident
que vous êtes dalle tenir peut-être dit
oui elles sont toutes vertes
j'ai envie de dire mr
pourquoi parce que je suis en bonne
santé et mais 80% d'eau potable le sont
aussi évidemment bien sûr qu'on tient à
la vie bien sûr que tout va vite
j'espère surtout qu'ici chacun d'entre
vous arrivera à suivre médecine
ah non j'ai déjà dit cannabis temps de
propriété pourtant tant de polémiques
textile isothermic curative relaxante
résistante écologique économique
on en a les preuves maintenant ça y est
sûrement pour lutter contre la maladie
en a aidé beaucoup on en a sûrement
besoin pour redémarrer mais je crois
qu'on a du mal à dire vivre ses rêves
évidemment il faut vivre ses rêves
plutôt que rêver sa vie être peureux
donc être peu heureux avoir peur de
l'être
j'ai besoin de vous dire en plus des le
chanteur de reggae j'ai travaillé deux
ans dans la recherche de fonds
associative super classe
en fait non j'étais juste dans la rue ou
dans les gares ne vous avais pas envie
de nous voir
ah vous dirais tape à deux minutes du
coup pour parler devant je suis très
très à l'aise je connais beaucoup sur le
sujet des vents j'en ai pris énormément
énormément
tellement que j'en ai fait mon élan et
si avec le vent on pouvait simplement
éclairer les gens c'est joli en plus moi
je viens des montagnes de france voisine
comme on dit ici à genève d'annecy j'ai
vu la montagne évolué notamment
certaines brume celles qui suivent
bizarrement les tracés des autoroutes
les montagnes on dit qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui ne se rencontrent pas pourtant on
est là on dit qu'elle nous gagne aussi
mais pour moi c'est à les préserver qu
on y gagnera et si dans cette montagne
je devais construire ma maison
j'aimerais être aussi à l'aise que dans
mes chaussons en toute saison qu'elle
ait des formes poétiques
artistique et que même si elle est dans
les normes
ça ne veuille pas dire qu'on ait des
limites en tout cas si l'entourage
change la façon dont on s'exprime il
doit avoir beaucoup de personnes de
qualité ce soit à voir que montrent
extreme tedx tiens je me suis demandé ce
que c'était au début parce que c'est un
test pour les moins de 18 ans j'ai ma
carte d'identité si je mets ou bien
est-ce que c'était un ted pour les
mathématiciens alors têtes inconnues ou
bien tu es d'improviser d'ailleurs c'est
ce que je fais c'est ce que vous faites
en permanence improvisé ça veut pas dire
qu'on n'a rien préparé
ça veut dire qu'on est prêt toujours
prêts quoi qu'il arrive pour redémarrer
et 7jours ça recommence ça redémarre
j'avais préparé programme l'ordre du
jour je quitte le port des amas reprend
la mer et malgré les instruments de
conduite combat car je ne peux pas
prévoir vents et marées qui sait quand
arrivera la tempête
il faut savoir souvent navigué à vue
improviser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]